[Music]
so what is new going on in your field
right now that that is like just
exciting the hell out of it oh man
really what's exciting to me about this
field is how our understanding of these
brown dwarfs I mean one of the reasons
that we study them is just because we're
they they're there and astronomers study
anything that's out there but it turns
out that these brown dwarfs are very
useful for understanding directly imaged
exoplanets and you might be like well
but there's lots and lots of planets but
most of the planets that we know about
we know about thousands of them okay but
we know about them indirectly like we
study the stars that the planets orbit
and we figure out stuff about the
planets based on the Stars okay but for
a very special type of planet we can
directly image the point like we can see
the light from the planet right which to
me is just huge so just to clarify what
you're saying is that the thousands of
exoplanets that are now in the catalog
yeah are only deduced by inference not
by direct observation well they're
direct observations of the star right of
the planet that's a widely known fact
yeah we it's we gloss over it because we
put out these pictures of you know what
we think the planets look like all the
Kepler releases and things like that and
they're beautiful
but my stick is that you know but
they're like the apartment listing
photos that you see on Craigslist their
furniture is all cardboard and
inflatable and wide-angle lens and blah
blah blah like they're artists
representations of you know we do have a
good understanding of those planets we
can measure a mass we can measure radius
we can maybe measure some composition
and things those pictures are those
mathematical compilations of what they
should yeahit's those artists are but
they're based on reality like as much as
possible you know the size of the planet
and what we think given the size or the
mass of the planet what we think the
composition should be what we think you
know if it had an earth-like atmosphere
okay yeah but it's in the Goldilocks
zone yeah then you throw some water in
it or if it's really over dense and it's
a
can iron planet and if it's really close
in then it that half of the planet is
going to be heated by the star and there
really it's just that it is yeah you're
gonna get in there and the you know the
place is going to be dirty and things
are gonna be a little bit crooked and
cockroaches and so here's what I want to
ask you something that is and I have no
idea what this is but I read a quick
article that I didn't get to finish no
because I was in the middle of doing
something but it caught my heart so
there is maybe an exoplanet I'm not sure
where it is or maybe it's not an
exoplanet but in measuring the dip in
light in this particular place okay well
because I'm so technical that's a we
call it okay so measuring the dip in
light that's a transit method of
discovering plane that's the way that
Kepler space telescope find the planet
only that is in a measured in a cyclical
time base because there's an orbit yeah
now they found this dip in light
someplace that is an anonymous is an
anomaly because it's not it's not doing
it on a regular time are you talking
about tabby stars yeah but we're not
calling a tabby star we're calling it
except that I have a hard time
pronouncing or less and boy agian I
think your last name is Boyajian because
it's a anyway it's another another
gender thing because men tend to get
things named after the last name and
women tend to get things named after
their first name and we're sort of we're
trying to treat everybody equally and so
we're trying to call it Boyajian star
instead of tabby star that's that yeah
every stars a lot better than boy